we're really living in bizarro world I
was watching the White House press
secretary Sean Spicer yesterday and he
said that it's quote somewhat sad that
people are still talking about the
presidential election which is weird
this Donald Trump has talked about it
every day over the last week and on
nearly 40% of all days since the
November election here's John Spicer
yesterday but you play a game for
quarters you play an election until
Election Day so well with all due
respect to her that's not how we're
gonna get to pick the date of the
elections on set by the Constitution
president one 300 left six electoral
votes and I think there's been plenty of
analysis on the election and where
people chose to spend their time and
their resources and their messaging and
I think it's somewhat sad that we're
still debating why the president won in
the faction that he did just recently
during a Reuters interview Donald Trump
passed out maps of the election results
to reporters two days ago
Donald Trump sent out a tweet which said
Trump Russia story was an excuse used by
the Democrats as justification for
losing the election perhaps Trump just
ran a great campaign Trump also
mentioned the election the day before
that and the five days before that and
on more than a third of the days since
the November 8th election Donald Trump
has mentioned the election result that's
just on Twitter based on a Washington
Post analysis of Donald Trump's Twitter
account on 68 of the 776 days since
November 8th Trump has mentioned the
election win in some way shape or form
on Twitter and then of course there's
all of the times outside of Twitter
where he has done it why is Trump so
obsessed with the election results could
it be because as I've been saying for
months Donald Trump never wanted to be
President he just wanted to win the
election period he spent 10 minutes
reminiscing about the election win at
his last rally we don't even know why
he's having these rallies he sounded you
know Pat the kid you went to high school
with who now is still talking about that
time he bullied someone or won a fight
or something like that and you're kind
of like we're adults now is there
nothing else to talk about at this point
I honestly think that Donald Trump would
be happier had the role switched in that
Trump had won the popular vote and
Hillary Clinton assumed the presidency
by the electoral college because he sees
it as a popularity contest and he can't
get over the fact that he lost the
popular vote by three million right if
Trump had won the popular vote by 3
million but lost the electoral vote he
could be number one not having to be
president which has we figured out he
doesn't really like doing number two he
could just be criticizing Hillary
Clinton which we know he really does
like doing number three claiming victory
in the popularity contest and number
four still running his businesses which
it seems like what he's really would
rather be doing anyway and number five
attacking the system corrupt and he
would be right in that argument oh
there's no doubt about that
breaking news though Sean Spicer
actually didn't lie during an answer he
said it's somewhat sad that people are
still talking about the election and he
was right about that of course he was
including Trump in that I think the
funny part is that Sean Spicer had the
winning point in that exchange which is
that the election wasn't held on October
28th everyone knew all along was going
to be on November 8th and yet he still
managed to create this gaffe on an
unforced error Trump needs to come up
with a second accomplishment it's a
sight right because you can't how long
is he going to cite that he won the
election is his main accomplishment and
I know that sometimes he talks about
well we are our big win is Neal Gorsuch
then the Senate had to literally go
nuclear
in order to get Neal Gorsuch in there
it's not exactly a major presidential
accomplishment is it I've heard Trump
brag that he's the first president in
decades to get a Supreme Court justice
confirmed in the first 100 days yeah
that's true
but also that is much more dependent on
circumstance me that you need to have an
open seat on the Supreme Court to make
that happen
right when Republican senators make
someone wait hundreds of days simply
waiting around for an election it's very
easy to do that in the first hundred
days it's been keyed up and waiting for
you to just walk up to it with a bat and
honestly I could do that I could look at
a list of names and just pick one that's
all he had to do because think tanks had
the list provided for him yeah I mean
just absolutely pathetic that his
accomplishments are having won the
election and having gotten Neel Gorsuch
on the Supreme Court today's episode of
the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker
we did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right-wing conspiracy
website Breitbart pulling their ads off
and you can get the free five-day home
Tryon from Warby Parker check out their
glasses I use them when I'm not wearing
contact lenses I started with the free
at-home trial they send you five pairs
of glasses you see which ones you like
you send them back and whichever one you
pick they will put your prescription in
- I like this because I can actually
show the glasses to other people and not
have to just decide on the spot like in
an eyeglass store the eyeglass industry
is controlled by very few corporations
that keep the prices very very high even
over $300 for prescription glasses with
Warby Parker they start at just 95 bucks
mine cost that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS